jason to leslie's point you know
president trump just signed in to affect
savannah's act which had to do with
communication between different federal
and state agencies for the purpose of
that communication for elevating in that
context missing and murdered indigenous
women but again it's that that same
pattern of the power differential and of
the systemic abuse of young girls and my
question to you is in your time
in legislature what would you say were
the biggest roadblocks to accomplishing
more legislation and more laws that
could help sort of shed light and break
wide open these webs of complicit
interstate illegal sex trafficking jason
i think one of the things we found is
that
and i was on the the house judiciary
committee i think one of the things you
found is a whole set of prosecutors that
were so
timid in their bringing forth cases that
there were a lot of cases that a lot of
people thought were maybe 50 50 but they
were so reluctant to bring them to the
jury i think what we've seen in the in
the high profile cases lately is that
these cases the juries get them right
the juries do figure this out and we
need more prosecutors to prosecute them
i concur with leslie i i hope more
victims can come forward i i hope these
victims have a at least a sense of some
justice but i got to tell you there are
a lot of us who've been watching from
the sidelines who really do believe that
it wasn't just her and it wasn't just
jeffrey epstein there were a whole horde
of people that were taking advantage of
these young women those people need to
be prosecuted they should be shaking in
their boots right now knowing that the
federal government is going to come get
them and prosecute them if this is the
end of the case i think a lot of us will
be very disappointed that they fell far
short of those that should be prosecuted
yeah joey jason mentions sometimes the
sort of timidity of prosecutors and i
think that's part of the problem with
media right it's like the eye of sauron
these spotlights on certain issues and
the second it's buttoned up then there's
on to another issue that everyone's
talking about but it's really important
for prosecutors for the doj for
legislators to stay committed so that
things like this don't fall by the
wayside so that people that don't have
voices aren't all of a sudden silenced
simply because the media has moved on
joey yeah these crowds committed never
go away for the victims they never have
gone away they didn't get shelled for 20
years and come back when this trial came
it's been a part of their life every
single day and so i don't know how
victims that that weren't part of this
trial feel i don't know if they feel
vindicated or if they feel left out
because the actual crime committed
against them hasn't has it gone to trial
but i will tell you this this is never
going to go away for her now either it's
it is the rest of her life it's prison
with any luck i hope she rots in jail
and then she can rot in hell after that
evil doesn't have a definitive face but
you're seeing it on her screen right now
you don't do these things to young girls
and get a second chance in my opinion
you've committed crimes that and sins
that are that are unforgivable in in my
world and uh and so i'm glad there's a
guilty verdict and i hope that if i
understood brett earlier
that there isn't really a predictive
maximum sentence because of the way
sentencing works so if there's a year
they can tack on there i hope they do if
nothing else that solidifies her life in
prison and maybe
it works as a catalyst to find out who
else might have uh might have committed
crimes for her to testify against them
and i don't care who it is i don't care
if it's politician i like or politician
i hate or a celebrity or some royalty if
somebody else if there's credible
evidence that they committed these
crimes i hope they go to trial too
right tyrus we've seen a lot of criminal
justice reform and changes take place at
the state level and some at the federal
level but here the sentencing
enhancements remain at the federal level
which some of which will apply here we
know that sentencing guidelines to
joey's point extend maximums but it will
be up to the judge allison nathan here
in this case to levy those sentences and
she's facing up to 65 years in prison
tyrus
well i hope that i hope the judge goes
for the jugular on this one but i'll
actually like to make a statement i'm
hoping that when we see with someone
who's conspiracy conspires who turns a
blind eye in her case even participated
but i hope all those bodyguards personal
assistants out there assistant producers
uh managers agents who complicitly allow
their their spoiled
clients to get away with these type of
behaviors for years and then when it all
comes out it's like well i was just
doing this now maybe we'll start seeing
them get arrested maybe we'll start
seeing them having to be held
responsible you're a bodyguard and
you're helping individuals hide the the
underage girl in their hotel room or
protecting him from the media i hope we
start seeing some of those individuals
who kind of fit the same description
that she was
start to get charges pressed against
them too because you know what you're
going to see a lot more whistles being
blown earlier you're going to start
seeing more people do the right thing
when they have to be held accountable
and i'm hoping that we see more
accountability not just to the
perpetrators like the pedophile that he
was but also the people around him the
assistants the drivers all those people
around them and helped him keep his
little secret for so long we'll see in
other aspects of life where we see other
entertainers rich people etc
that do these type of things and it's
more prevalent than we you could
possibly imagine start to be held
accountable i think i'm hoping this is a
step in the right direction hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else